yeah I know anybody what are you doing
Bob I'll talk do it go go
hi everybody we're back we got to find
food now now now we gotta find morsels
on rabbits we only want to retake food
so yeah really
that food eat that seed I'm gonna hunt
rabbits or the goddamn rabbits did he
even pick up the seed there was seed
right there no what is this examine
green mushroom I don't know what we're
doing only comes out at night where's
all their habits okay you're there I
have God okay we're gonna work together
I got a trap I got rap skills rang at
ordeals scare the rabbit towards me oh
that way dude
no no no no what do you know what do you
know funnel it out no no no no no no way
you tried it trying to go towards the
hole I got ideas we win yeah I gotta get
I gotta get in a boat and got it whoa
snap murder okay what is dead
now we need another one okay why are
there so few rabbits around here we can
do this there's another hole up here
there's gotta be there's lots of holes
but that doesn't mean there's lots of
rabbits we're never gonna be able to
progress anywhere if we can't find
rabbits that's exactly what that's
supposed to mean eat those pig heads can
I eat them oh god I'm about to die I am
about to die do you need a fire do you
want to cook you're more so I'm just
gonna go back and light the bowl Oh
accommodate I look it we can do this
we're like it we're like scraping by the
skin of our teeth we're not able to
actually do anything okay so I'm gonna
cook these seeds up seed seed seed seed
seed seed morsel uh we need oh [ __ ] um
oh good okay so I barely really got away
god the seeds do not do nothing oh we're
in trouble
oh there's another rabbit up there yi yi
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you yeah
you think you're gonna go home I found a
berry bush I found a berry bush okay
don't dig it up apparently God what we
didn't leave a single berry bush to come
back to that was her I found a carrot Oh
watch your berry bushes did you die no I
didn't die but the rabbit got away I was
so sad mark I am gathering food
I found five berry bushes right here I
he'll like that soup
miss jackpot I'm coming man okay thanks
buddy I'm coming buddy
same dude the last episode before I'm
about to save you my traps they keep
going in their holes just stay alive
just that's great oh okay I got it right
back right now no no I'm fine I'm fine I
got a rep okay I'm good I'm good you
keep getting the plus or off food that I
imagine you're looking at right now
there's just yeah and you don't even
know it's it's like batshit crazy yeah
from the heavens just endless food did
you eat yeah you left a trap over here
there's something in it ooh oh yeah I
left that out I couldn't find it because
it was dark oh that's a good idea we
just leave the traps right on the things
will be fine oh okay this is good this
is good
no smart you didn't you did smart all
right I have eight berries and three
carrots right now for carrots good job I
have three morsels ah bloop okay I have
three morsels it's gonna be night again
yeah this was a productive day
fast-forward and Bill the point where we
can actually survive who knows what
we'll do
yeah I got another one so I got for food
murder okay we're good oh we're so good
yeah yeah something is coming what is
coming um something's coming what is
that what do we do about that hear that
right yeah here oh did you see that the
top right no what was that don't go
after it we need to go okay we got a
plan okay food food let's go this is
that dad quest for poop we need epic
quest for poop music frightened meow I I
can't wait to hear what that turns out
to be what is that
Oh gotta be something now did you just
look around the internet there's gotta
be something yeah everybody on the
internet search it up yourselves or what
for God's sake don't Google epic quest
for poop music yeah don't
do that but here is the epic quest for
pop music that I do have nice to leave
her that good what is that that's
probably a good thing right something is
coming you're still a boy good okay you
need to find people o people o people o
people o people o how are we gonna kill
the bee Flo rabbits everywhere oh my I
know holy [ __ ]
I'm setting traps oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] we
don't have enough traps okay I'm gonna
go oh my god there's so many rabbits No
scare him down go down you [ __ ]
someone is coming I got another sweet
kill it no time to cook to eat it good
enough I think it cooking only gives you
health back like the only reason to cook
it when you want health back I think it
still gives a standard amount of food
agents that your traffic yeah
yo you [ __ ] go towards the trap you
[ __ ] another one do you need it
alright I got water oh god no no that
was what Otto says the wolves those are
wolves get on the road Ron the road I'm
on Ron Ron Ron Ron
oh god you're gonna die they're so fast
oh why is this happening to us we just
want to live a FIFA lows all right
hardest boys harvest the poop on the run
let's do this I'm trying to get the poop
oh god okay that's got a boots over here
I got a poop oh my god we just finally
found the quest for poop I got you more
perilous than I thought it was gonna be
wow
I don't know why I bother Biblos are
killing it Oh
oh yes yes yes yeah and there's plus for
me and they told you people Oh
oh my god people people oh you guys are
the best [ __ ] dudes ever oh my god oh
we were
and oh man okay I did not expect that
okay so just saved our bacon oh oh I'm
seeing shadow monsters that's good oh
you're a little insane that's okay just
do what you can
I'm the catch as many rabbits akin I
know my heart was a tense man I knew
something was happening it just didn't
know what just found a pile of twigs and
a skeleton oh okay
all right we're okay all right come here
flowers I need some sanity all right all
right more poop so shall we head home or
oh we're just gonna hang around the
Beefalo sand why should we need like I
think 12 poop total I have oh good let's
just don't attack the Beefalo that's for
sure the beach hiding ooh he's hiding
poop right here oh come on be flow don't
be shy about your poop you're a good
pooper we like your poop hey your poop
is fantastic man yeah you got me on my
best on us man yeah dubby shot be proud
be proud of the poop man all right I'm
gonna get to one more rabbit and then
hopefully there'll be a little more poop
here's another poop here's to more poop
gather up all I got uh five poops
how many poops you get I currently have
sit well where the hell is seven poops
seven poops that's eleven poops just get
one more we'll head back home is it 5 +
7 12 ye yes you're right it's been a
while since I took a bath let's go home
yeah oh shut up Bob I'm perfectly sane
let me just catch one of the more of
these things
oh we walked right into my trap I'm just
gonna keep grabbing the poop man I love
this poop they're more poop it's good
poop man I'm going insane why it's going
so insane probably cuz I have to mention
murdering so many small animals and
picking up poop oh just killing things
make us go insane I guess stoic don't go
that way no no no oh no no ran around
ooh there's a flower I need to pick that
yeah I get it
maybe holding my lighter does that oh is
that why oh god that's why I doing
insane because I was holding my lighter
and that's what's making me go hey I
should I should lighting gunfire
develops that's good ok uh you're not
picking up the seeds
man the seeds are free food you okay
hey I'm picking up the seeds they're
free food man don't what I'm gonna pick
up the saplings as we go I swear if you
really need some sapling more insane I
am when I look at your face I I notice
your eyes are wide you like that on fire
nervous okay don't judge me but don't
touch anything that's flammable when
you're nervous well I'm going home or
there's a bunch of berry bushes you want
to have to eat then yeah what's not
let's let's not do anything crow fine
all Jason's objective Drecker poop you
get no big deal on my word whatever
don't trust me with anything murmur I
mean I'm not the one who's just lighting
stuff on fire very dark - I don't have a
torch oh I can make a torch though we're
almost over well so we are home okay I'm
firing away for a moment I'm gonna go
flower picking in the dark that's gonna
be good for my sanity ha ha that doesn't
doesn't seem worth it don't mind me
while I rave insanely in the woods huh
fire hi okay all right all right I'm
fertilizing fertilizing all of our
bushes with my poop
please go god that sounds so hot we
didn't get enough we didn't get enough
poop I never thought I would want more
poop in my life but we are for poops
short of fertilizing apart bushes dammit
I knew we should have gotten more poop
tribe I got a bunch of seeds and all
kinds of stuff I don't see any flowers
around here for some reason like I
picked a couple or they all went
do they not grow back we must grow back
there's got to be more flowers around
here somewhere I'm gonna lose my mind
not in real life
I don't really know good that's good
yeah I bet you were really worried about
that Bob huh yeah no I
you know it's man yeah yeah
whatever okay I'm coming back I'm I
don't think I'm insane enough to light
things on fire now even though I'm
walking in with the torch okay
oh those look delightful I could so
easily light them on fire I should very
much stay away from that show tonight
yeah let's not light anything on fire
let's stop let's not do that at all
Oh God milady okay I'm dipping back into
insanity I need flowers I need flowers
man even you're starting to trip out on
me man
your face is getting really weird I'm
doing okay I've been too much fire
hopefully that doesn't light anything
else on fire
that's totally [ __ ] on weather shadow
monsters I see shadow monsters too
giggity okay everything is fine
everything is awesome just look at the
ground and everything is awesome we're
gonna get berries soon there's gonna be
so many berries we can go back need more
poop in the field of Drive it's soo
there's so many rabbits yeah we're gonna
be fine
yeah no it's uh yeah it's gone it's gone
well yeah I am on fire I lit myself on
ha ha ha I seem to be on fire ok then
that was good I should stand over here
so you you can't let anything else on
fire you get so nervous you light
yourself on fire apparently maybe I was
standing on something and it got let in
fire but we're alive I'm going to go to
the field of bees and pick some goddamn
flowers so I don't light anything wait
fire ha ha I I guess I'm gonna go to the
right I have a green mushroom I'm good
yeah I can give it brings my CD ok there
bill on his go well and Mark it's a bit
out of control
yes I spit hot fire I'm going I'm going
into the land of berries and honey good
please ooh and poop berries honey and
poop there's no poop over here but there
this is where so where I got all them
berries before ok there's there's a way
to control the Beefalo by the way I know
there's a way to hurt him or I would
imagine there
way to hurt him in some way not hurt
heard her no but I wanted to hurt them
why would you want to hurt the gentle
Beefalo who give us raining poop from
the skies who descending from the
heavens man unlimited poop when you say
like that yeah you don't want to hurt
him inning oh it's raining
Oh God rain hurts me rains bad oh yeah
Oh God
oh uh where are you where are you oh I'm
coming home welcome home do I - um you
need to get a hug a tree or something uh
we need to make a fire I I'm all right
whirring I'm comin I'm close I'm to the
right I'm coming I don't see you um I'm
I'm I don't seem like really close to
home wait I'm not home I'm in the land
of honey's and bees oh god okay okay I'm
gonna pick a red mushroom I'm gonna go
see whatever I can i build a structure
yes go do all you want I don't know but
I'm gonna pick whatever's over here
there's berries there's carrots I'm
gonna come back we're gonna have food I
can't carry any more and they eat it
uh uh you're gonna be fine you're gonna
live you're gonna live a long life well
how do I um uh hey wall sign I passed by
lightning and I'm currently on fire I
have nine to fire you
that's right I'm immune to fake house I
need four boards I need a pigskin Oh God
Oh No rabbit hutch good Oh okay I'm fine
actually I forgot that it was totally
immune to fire bird cage uh checkered
flooring wooden flooring cobblestones Oh
whatever boring good Morgan I'm looking
at the structures Wow why do you need
all that much stuff to build a thing
there's nothing that has a roof well are
you still hurting yes well okay that's
bad Oh like I'm buzz ding I'm shorting
out in the rain no chance you got uh 57
oh yeah cook some food get that up I
have no food
oh come on we just put poop in the
bushes there they're doing nothing man
where's the poop doing it right dammit
uh it'll grow in like a day maybe they
grow back everyday I don't know I don't
know what they do they'll come back
yes shut up you're gonna be fine go on
my trap bunny rabbit I swear to God all
right I'm coming back I got a red
mushroom that heals you right yes oh no
no y-you go that way
I know they're okay the rain stops I'm
okay I'm okay
okay now everything is fine still day I
don't need to come back I uh I will
survive okay that's what's important
I got some traps huh all right so we can
end this episode here we're not God dead
died we're not dead yeah dads whoo okay
so like oh man yeah all right I gotta
have the love to say yeah anything to
say Bob I need food
all right no I got I got nothing
valuable to say that's what that means
okay so thank you everybody so much for
watching and joining us for don't starve
we are we gonna play more now ah not not
right now maybe not yeah gonna play more
though
yeah I got school in the morning yeah
Bob's got that weird Law School thing
that he does so what in the world is all
that so Wow my mom does frog hurts
oh no oh god oh god berries
none of these berry bushes that I picked
earlier have grown back yet more beer
that's cuz I just picked them they grew
back and I picked them so thank you all
so much for watching and as always we
will see you in the next video
that's good here's a video meet Dan some
fish so many things like change for
months oh sorry